die alte wohnung ist längst leer die
erinnerungen bleiben auf youtube für
immer bestehen
[Musik]
doch es war an der zeit für eine neue
bleibe und neue erinnerungen special
präsentation
herzlich willkommen in unserer neuen
wohnung wir sind nämlich umgezogen und
zwar vor vier monaten vor vier monaten
ist es jetzt hatte ich glaube dass das
halbwegs eingerichtet ist jetzt ist es
soweit und das zeigen jetzt kommt noch
mal mit in die küche
[Musik]
das ist es einmal wir haben hier an
meiner selbst zusammen geschwister der
küche gut haben sie nicht selber gemacht
natürlich gesagt hat drei stunden mit
diesem typ da von dieser küchen beratung
daran haben uns überlegt wie wenigsten
relativ kleine am besten nutzen von köln
ist mit 3d modellen gemacht und so und
dann als es entstand war richtig ist
dass kein echtes holz zieht aber echt
geil aus diese oberfläche ist auch cool
generell schöne farblichen abstimmungen
wir haben hier waschmaschine und
trockner und waschmaschine
das war es wenn ihr mehr zur küche sehen
möchtet so viel macht dass wir mal
wieder sind könnt euch das gerne meint
karte schlafzimmer ist einmal hier rum
[Musik]
er hat auch schon ein süßes kleines
häuschen
davon kann jetzt immer so
die ecke ist mir so meine ecke hier
schreibe ich schneide ich fühle mich
manchmal auch meine videos das ist ein
wunderschöner ausblick für den ganzen
tag für mich viele pflanzen und ich habe
mir so einen schminktisch weil sowas
darf hier auch mal sein
wir haben wartet sich nicht so viel
platz deswegen muss sowas her und wir
haben hier unsere natürlich unser bett
das haben wir auch erst vor zwei wochen
zecke gekriegt das waren auch ein video
gemacht indem man es aufgebaut haben wir
ganz lustig massives holz weil man hier
schöner prix schäden sieht richtig gut
aus mit schönen stall füßen die man
leider eigentlich sieht außer in diesen
kunden trotzdem laufen werden ansonsten
garderobe da muss man wirklich rein
schauen weil das ist absolut zerknittert
wenn wir alles denn und ungeordnet hier
hinten ist unsere wäsche schön sortiert
auch richtig geil gemalt und wäsche
dunkle wäscherei sich genau so alles vor
alfred so nennt mancher dieses video
wird übrigens meine telefon gesprochen
sollte unter anderem deswegen sind
sachen wir das hier möglich da kann man
ja genau da sieht man alles ein bisschen
farbig aus ist eigentlich ziemlich geil
mal mit licht zum spielen zu können
davon gibt es aber später vor allem
natürlich im büro
[Musik]
dass unser so richtig geil dieses ding
verleiht den ganzen rechner ein bisschen
farbe sei nicht geil
dadurch wirkt der raum nicht so weiß ist
nicht das größte ball trotzdem hat
eigentlich für alle sie haben ja schon
schön schrank wir haben eine heizung der
dusche ein duschbad das hat auch schon
haben wir uns schon bald hier nein ich
habe mit 400 hier gebildet aber ich habe
mich schon mal hier
mit diesen worten kann auch gleich nach
der macht dafür tatsächlich einer der
wenigen mit bringen wir auf unserer
letzten wohnung weil die meisten sachen
die eigentlich bisschen so zu rücken
haben wir alles zurückgelassen aber
diese couch haben wir noch bereiten
wohnung nicht antreffen büro datum hat
auch schon etliche male druck sind wer
tisch tatsächlich auch gefehlt wir haben
hier auch richtig de kurs ist auch mal
90 mal drum kümmert ja allergie wollen
wir uns so was nicht so beachtet da war
halt alles mehr so sehr errichten und
die sachen so ein dass es praktisch ist
das funktioniert und jetzt ist es halt
so hey wir haben das machen worauf er
bock hab ne coole lampe mit federn
worauf ich aber besonders stolz bin ist
dieses ziel will abbott ist ein
handwerker aufgehoben wenn die löcher im
boden
du hast mit dem zusammen ich habe
irgendwas davon gemacht und ich bin
richtig stolz denn auch den kabelkanal
ich gemacht habe dass auch ein mega
highlight hier natürlich dieser teppiche
haben generell die euch bestimmt auch
wenn wir wie auch auf einem kanal wo ich
sehr darauf achte dass alles ein
bisschen orange bläulich ist darauf
haben wir auch generell in der ganzen
wohnung tatsächlich ist also die
einzigen farben die man hier so richtig
dominant findet sind eigentlich grau bis
schwarz orange und blau
und wie langsam auch es tatsächlich
gestern heran gezimmert gekriegt
deswegen ist auch das video erst heute
aufgenommen nach vier monaten hat
wirklich ist seit ewig muss einfach zehn
wochen waren dass man ist so verträgt
den tisch richtig krass also der hat ja
mal station kostet 300 euro gekriegt
weil jochen hahn in denen in ihrer
wohnung ich ganz cool ist angesagt ist
dass wir überall richtig große fenster
haben also in jedem jahr haben riesige
fenster sind jetzt natürlich alle nicht
so guten defense meisten zensiert oder
wir haben die rolle herunter gemacht
weil wir natürlich wollen dass ihr wisst
ihr wo genau das ist eigentlich schade
weil man kann sagen dass wir ein
ziemlich klein ausblick an und das tut
mir stunde sind wir dass wir die nicht
heilen können aber so ist es mal hier
essen gemeinsam jeden tag zusammen was
leckeres und schauen nebenbei an diesem
fernseher eine schöne serie dann
anschließend gestern meistens mich auf
die couch statt drüben wo wir dann
einfach umstellen und halten auch die
serie fertig schauen aber das ist nicht
die einzige auch nicht der einzige
fernseher denn diese wunderschöne also
echt richtig geil der treppe also ich
finde richtig geil
diese treppe die von regierungen und die
verzogen büro in das herzstück gern noch
mal schön die beiden schönen pflanzen
natürlich den halo magenta aktiviere die
szene arbeit
[Musik]
erstmals kommt ist echt ein richtig
geiles gefühl sie sehr offene fläche zu
sehen
ihr hof kam waren wir erstmal komplett
geflecht von dem ausblick den leider
nicht sehen kannst du das war das
sowieso zuerst hingezogen hat aber
allgemein so wie dieser raum ist auch
mit der schönen holzdecke und den ganzen
balken darin sieht schon ziemlich cool
aus und so hat sie ein bisschen glück
gehabt bei der wohnungssuche wie man das
von einem youtuber erwartet spielt
technik hier natürlich eine sehr große
rolle von smart tv über die smart led
lampen bis hin zum staubsauger roboter
über mal ganz smartphone von der telekom
kann alles miteinander kommunizieren
hallo magenta aktiviere die szene
magenta an
ich zeige euch mal was das büro jetzt
zusammen mit der smart home home base 2
und den anderen geräten von smartphones
punkt.de so drauf hat
einmal haben wir diese alten
heizungsregler durch die smarthome
heizkörperthermostate ausgetauscht
wodurch man die raumtemperatur nicht nur
auf den grad genau steuern kann sondern
dass auch von unterwegs weil ich den
fenstern und der schiebetür einen tür-
fenster- kontakt verpasst hat gehen die
heizung nicht einfach so wenn ich das
fenster aufmacht und dadurch die
kernenergie mehr verloren fürs filmen
aber auch fürs wohlbefinden ist licht
essentiell deswegen habe ich mir viele
verschiedene profile für alle
alltagssituation erstellt wie zum
beispiel das hier
hallo magenta aktiviere die szene
fernsehen es fühlt sich gut an so eins
mit seiner umgebung zu sein
über den link in der video beschreibung
findet ihr zum smartphone punkt.de von
der telekom wo er alles findet was man
für ein smartes zu hause braucht und in
diesem setting sieht man auch recht egal
diese ganzen lampen ja die richtig gut
zur geltung
das videoportal hallo magenta aktiviere
die szene arbeit
vielleicht merkt extrem grün wie haben
sie sagen sich viele pflanzen gestellt
ich wollte unbedingt in eine flache für
clown
ich wollte unbedingt eine pflanze die
relativ at ist ein großes ein mensch und
das ist die auf jeden fall die kakteen
die ich unbedingt haben wollte das auch
ganz lustig weil die sophie hat keinen
bock auf kakteen weil warum auch immer
sie sticht ich glaube ich dass man
irgendeinen trauma mit kakteen aber die
sehen hinter klares und da glaube ich
krieg sogar die sophie nicht in sicht
bisher hat es nicht geklappt wir
ansonsten ja auch ziemlich viele möbel
hier neu gekauft es gibt aber auch ein
paar die wir mitgenommen haben aus der
alten wohnung zum beispiel diese
community kennt ihr vielleicht schon
dann auch mal ein schreibtisch den
kinder wahrscheinlich schon ich habe
endlich den neuen stuhl weil der alle
war so richtig fröhlich und knapp sehr
knapp auch mittlerweile schon aber das
klappt auch wie gesagt abgestimmt habe
ich schon alles grau blau holz farben
holz waren auch schon links bestieg
punkt
ja ich wollte allen auch wieder der
erstmals gebrochen ist dass man noch mal
schlafen aber trotzdem schön stahl und
holz das beste halten ist auch eine
schöne kommode die ist noch nicht
eingerechnet da kommen ganz viele pakete
ran und ganz viele sachen die man
unbedingt sehen muss hier ist zeigt dass
man ständig sehen muss und zwar mein
youtube flickr und jetzt hat eigentlich
so das herzstück von büro natürlich weil
es mache ich mir videos arbeiten hier
der schreibtisch da habe ich tatsächlich
relativ viel nicht um das
kabelmanagement gekümmert hier natürlich
auch die drei monitore die müssen aber
das kind ja eh schon aus meinen ganzen
videos was hier noch nicht so oft
gesehen habe ist wahrscheinlich dieses
klavier
das habe ich ja erst am letzten video
und ich finde eine ganz cool hier und
ich spiele tatsächlich auch halbwegs oft
also bestimmt den zweiten mal kurz
zurückgehen um zwei klaviere das kommt
dann einfach im wohnzimmer wo diese
riesige leere weiße stelle war
das ist mein ding der grund wenig zumal
im 22 geburtstag also mein letzter
geschenkt gekriegt hat das kennt er
wahrscheinlich schon wenn ihr meine
zweikanalton erfolgt oder meines teams
für die hoch war das war natürlich immer
noch den richtig geilen ausblick von
unserem balkon aus auf wir haben da am
tisch stehen und verstehe dass man da
schön draußen grillen kann deswegen
wieder und auch ein grill haben und es
ist ja tausende pflanzen
ich muss echt sagen es ist richtig geil
hier mitten in der stadt einfach im
sommer dann einfach obst her auf dem
balkon zu aber so richtig welche
komische sein gegner gut komisch ich bin
also in kall aspekt sind natürlich die
ganzen lampen hier die man hier einfach
alle steuern kann das ist schon richtig
geil wird auch richtig krass sein für
die videos also die videos natürlich
auch so mit der grund warum die eine
neue wohnung gebraucht haben weil die
alte war einfach schon groß genug so zum
wohl aber um unsere videos zu machen war
das büro oder einfach viel zu klein und
hier hat man richtig viel platz wird
danach in echt froh dass es ist so ne
heftige wohnung es ist einfach unfassbar
geisteskrank also das muss man
allerdings sagen wir haben teilweise die
probleme gehabt die überhaupt zu füllen
weil er noch so groß wir haben uns
wirklich stundenlang gedanken gemacht
was wir jetzt noch hinstellen können so
leer aus das ist echt einmal pizza wer
hätte gedacht das war's von diesem video
über den link in der video beschreibung
kommt ist ein smartphone punkt.de von
der telekom die dieses video unterstützt
haben und wenn ihr sehen wollt welche
videos in zukunft mit diesen coolen
lichtern und alles mögliche kommen er
laboriert kenntnissen kanal und
ansonsten wieder gut
[Musik]
ja